oui on pourrait partir du week-end
prochain où ça je sais pas trouvé
banlieue on se prend un petit hôtel
sympa resto sur le port plateau de
fruits de mer bonjour malades massage
pas joué comment ça je te demande si tu
as joué
bah oui je sais pas tu as tu entendu si
j'ai entendu au bain alors ben moi j'ai
pas joué tu vois à puis tu parle tout le
temps après l'amour tu fais pas tu pia
pyatt quoi être plus tu es tout était
tout excité m excuse moi c'est quoi ce
reproche pas envie de me faire chier
quoi
or nous d'avant la pêche oui j'ai la
pêche oui oui bah oui à la pêche et à la
pêche de quelqu'un qui s'est débarrassé
d'une corde et elle va du prêteur à
gauche face à galles bah ouais
franchement peut-être que je préférais
que tu fasses ta gueule j'ai vraiment
l'impression de vivre une mascarade
puis j'en ai marre de poser dans le voir
assis toi qui veux toujours et pas moi
je signale que ça m'aide